the Trump administration says the
president's threat to shut down the
border with Mexico is no bluff Customs
and Border Protection says the
immigration system is past the breaking
point because of a surge of families
from Central America asking for asylum
the president criticized Democrats and
Mexico yesterday tweeting homeland
security is being so very nice but not
for long men well Bojorquez is in El
Paso Texas a key location in the border
controversy men well good morning good
morning the OL Passover so such a spike
in migrants that last week officials
here say they were forced to how some of
them under this border bridge they've
now been moved to another facility but
if you take a look from above we can
show you the problem here and that is
that shutting down the border could
threaten billions of dollars in trade
the president will do everything he can
if closing the ports of entry mean that
that's exactly what he intends to do the
president's aides argued Sunday the move
may be necessary as Border Patrol
officials deal with an influx of
migrants many coming as families before
the hot summer months last month more
than 75,000 people were apprehended the
highest in over a decade in a letter to
Congress homeland security secretary
Kirsten Neilson called the surge of
migrant arrivals a dire situation and
said the agency is facing a system-wide
meltdown there's a very good likelihood
that I'll be closing the border next
week and that'll be just fine with me
president Trump blamed Mexico and other
Central American countries Friday for
not stopping caravans of migrants moving
toward the US border and on Saturday the
State Department cut off US aid to El
Salvador Guatemala and Honduras a
decision Democrats warned could worsen
the humanitarian crisis presidents
cutting off aid to these countries will
not solve that problem back at the
border if there are concerns a shutdown
could hurt businesses and consumers in
the u.s. many people from Mexico come
here to buy things they need trade
between Mexico and Texas here along the
El Paso border crossing alone totaled
more than 80 billion dollars last year
and thousands of people cross just to go
to war
every day the president is set to visit
the border on Friday he'll be making a
stop in Calexico California biana as we
know this is already a true humanitarian
crisis as well man well thank you